broadly speaking our proposed baseline
level what we have called
level zero is the closest to normality
that we think we can safely get to
without more effective treatments for
covid
or a vaccine against covet and remember
we are hopeful for both of these
developments in the months ahead
level zero is broadly comparable to the
position
we reached in august when the virus was
very suppressed in scotland
but still a threat at this level we
would be able to meet indoors with eight
people from three households and most
businesses would be open
albeit with safety measures in place
level one it sees slightly more
restrictions for example indoor
household meetings
would reduce to six people from two
households but there would still be a
reasonable degree of normality overall
and i would describe that as broadly
similar to the situation we were at in
scotland
around mid-september as cases started to
rise again
but prevalence was still fairly low
now getting back to level one and then
to level zero
and being able to stay there is what we
are aiming for this side of better
treatment or a vaccine
however levels two and three are
intended to apply at times
such as now when transmission is higher
and rising
level two entails restrictions broadly
similar to those currently in place just
now
outside the central belt so limitations
on hospitality
and no gatherings inside people's homes
and
level three is broadly similar to the
tougher restrictions
which currently apply across the central
belt with much of hospitality being
closed
completely there are however some key
differences for example we envisage
restaurants being able to open at least
partially in level three
levels two and three are intended to
apply
if necessary for relatively short
periods of time to bring
transmission down and under control
and finally level four the highest level
which of course we would not use
unless absolutely necessary would apply
when transmission
rates are or are threatening to become
very high
with corresponding pressure on the nhs
and perhaps the risk of the nhs
being overwhelmed the restrictions at
level 4
are closer to a full lockdown for
example non-essential shops would have
to close
at level four however even under level
four restrictions
six people from up to two households
could still meet outdoors
there would be no limit on outdoor
exercise for individuals
and we would seek to keep manufacturing
and construction businesses open
albeit with safety measures in place in
other words
we do not envisage returning to a
situation
as severe as the first lockdown imposed
back
in late march and i hope that helps to
reinforce
an important point we are not back at
square one
we have made progress in tackling the
virus and we have
more tools now at our disposal to help
control it
and today's framework will help us i
hope to make
further progress i can also confirm
that our objective at all levels is as
far as possible to keep
schools open though with necessary
safety measures in place that is
in our view in the best interests of
children and young people
so that is a summary of the proposed
levels you can read the detail online
and we will consult with stakeholders
and make any necessary amendments ahead
of parliament debating it on tuesday
before i move on to my next point though
i want to say something
directly to people who were shielding up
until the end of july
anyone who was shielding should as a
minimum follow the guidance we provide
for the general population that in
itself offers
a substantial degree of protection but
today's publication
also provides additional advice for each
level of restrictions
for activities like going to work school
shopping and having contact with others
you will find this in the framework
document itself
and the chief medical officer will be
sending you a letter today
you can follow this advice to the letter
if you want to however if you want to
understand the evidence and take more
informed decisions we will shortly be
publishing a guide to help you do that
and if you need practical assistance
remember that the national helpline
remains
open for advice and support the number
is 800
treble 1 4 000. we know how hard
the last few months have been for
everybody but particularly for those in
the shielding category so we are
determined to give you the advice and
support you need
to stay safe and well now for all of us
including those in the shielding
category our aim must be to live with
this virus
under the fewest restrictions possible
we want to get to and then stay at level
zero or level one
of the framework and the good news that
which we should all hold on to
is that we know this is possible because
we got there back in the summer
it depends on all of us following all of
the rules and advice
and doing all that is asked of us but it
also depends on government
putting all of the right supporting
systems in place
so as well as setting out the levels of
intervention the strategic framework
sets out how we will support
compliance with facts and other rules
this includes support for self-isolation
which is a crucial part
of test and protect we also set out our
further planned increases to test and
capacity
before the end of this year we will have
capacity in scotland to do
at least 65 000 tests every day
some of the increase in capacity will
come from the uk wide
lighthouse laboratory system but most of
it will be in the
nhs scotland laboratory system we've
also published a paper today with
recommendations from our clinical
advisors
on the best use of this extra capacity
our top priority must always be ensuring
that we can quickly test people with
covered like symptoms
and we know that demand for that will
increase
over the winter period beyond that our
clinical advice is telling us to focus
on protecting those
most at risk from covet we already do
regular testing of care homeworkers
but i can confirm that we will move now
to introduce regular testing of
designated visitors to care homes
to nhs staff who visit care homes to
care at home
workers and to anyone who is admitted to
hospital
in an emergency this is an approach
designed to reduce the risk of covered
spreading
in the settings where we know it can do
most harm
however we will also extend testing of
asymptomatic people for surveillance
purposes
and to help manage outbreaks